a victim of a long time las vegas pampa
we'll get to that story in just a moment
but first taking a look at more road
construction on the horizon this time
you'll see closures on eastern under the
u.s 95. madison kimbrough joins us live
in the area with the details and shares
what this could mean for locals along
the stretch madison
stretch madison yeah this 10-day project
is set to last until october 13th now
take a look behind me where you're
really going to see this entire road as
cars are zipping through as of now but
like i mentioned starting tonight that
is when it's going to close at 10 pm and
half of the eastern avenue bridge is set
to be demolished
all this week drivers in this area have
probably noticed some lane restrictions
and now with the demolition underway
this entire area will be blocked off for
drivers you will be able to access
through stuart avenue and bonanza but
access directly under the bridge will
not be available the best way to get to
those streets would be to take maryland
parkway locals around the area say they
aren't looking forward to the delays but
know the work needs to get done it's
going to slow down everything especially
access to the schools traffic in the
morning on my way to work is already bad
so this is just going to make everything
worse but i guess if people are patient
and they plan but still it's going to be
an inconvenience access to your local
businesses will still be available it
just may take some more time this
construction work is part of the nevada
department of transportation's 40
million dollar viaduct rehabilitation
project
and again this closure starts tonight at
10 pm and will last through 10 p.m on
october 13. reporting live on eastern
avenue madison kimbrough live local now